Now there is one thing that we
have not been able to iterate
over, and that is the regular,
old, plain object. Plain object
is not an iterable, so I've
tried to use for const prop of
Apple, and I tried to console
log property. When we try that,
it tells me that there is no
symbol.iterator. We'll talk a
lot more about what symbols are
in those videos. For now, what
we need to know is that you
cannot iterate over an object.
What are some of our options?
There is going to be an object
method called entries. Just like
we used .entries against our
array, we're going to be able to
do .entries against an object.
We don't have that yet, but if
you take a look at the TC39
proposal here, we'll see that
object.values and object.entries,
they are in stage four and they
will be included in ES2017.
Those are coming, and you can
already polyfill it. We'll talk
a lot more about polyfilling,
but if you would like to use
that simple solution, you can go
ahead and you can use .entries.
If you cannot use a polyfill,
let's take a look at some of our
other options here. We could do
this, object.keys. Now, what
does that do? Object.keys will
take in an object, like an apple,
and it will return to us an
array of all of the keys. We
don't have values yet, and we
don't have entries yet, but we
can get the keys. What that will
do, let's see, color, size,
weight, and sugar. If you want
to be able to get the value,
we'll say const value=apple,
with the prop in it. Then we
should be able to console log
the value prop. Not the
cleanest solution, because you
sort of have to reach outside to
get this object here, but that
will work for you if that's
exactly what you need to use.
Pick your own, of course you can
always use your regular, old for-
in. That is going to give you a
very similar one, you don't need
to mess with any of those. My
recommendation is until we have
objects and entries, let's stick
with just using a for-in for
objects.